nous sommes en présence de madame de la
scène une femme
a vécu
très longtemps 91 ans ce qui est
incroyable cette époque là
et dans notre inconscient collectif
madame desbassyns représente la femme
diabolique qui incarne toute cette
période d'esclavagé
cette douloureuse que nous avons tous
connu et en ce qui me concerne j'ai
voulu représenter une madame desbassyns
avec un peu plus notamment d'humanité
vous voyez que il ya un chien à ses
pieds
et donc ça lui apporte une certaine
chaleur humaine et elle est en train de
vie et son code de son code de noix
c'est pour montrer que qu'elle était
malgré tout respectueuse du droit de
l'époque et par ailleurs vous voyez
qu'elle lit le code noir malgré son âge
très avancé sans lunettes
et c'est une femme qui qui était l'une
des plus grosses fortunes de france
c'est un personnage incontournable en
tout cas du patrimoine historique d'une
autre il est là elle se retrouve dans
son jardin assis sur un banc de 10 style
de l'époque
c'est une oeuvre qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre d'une scénographie que j'ai
réalisée sur le thème du esclavage de
marronnage et madame desbassyns a tout à
fait sa place et madame desbassyns
réalisé dans un gros galets que j'ai
trouvé pris sous le pont de la rivière
des pluies
c'est une roche pintade comme on appelle
ici avec des cristaux blancs d'oeuf elle
se bat et ce galet a été travaillée au
marteau et au burin et puis avec
un peu de polissage à cet endroit